[Music]
but you
are
different
because you are watching this video
hi i'm anthony cap accreditation the
highly acclaimed certificate in the lab
that will cap debate any future
partnerships
for you
[Music]
for your lab
the reason why you get it is because it
shows you're legit it shows you are the
captain
of the lab
who knows how to run it effectively with
clear documents on everything about your
lab and actually following through so
that's why we're going to go over an
overview of how to get cap accreditation
in your lab so let's get started cap
stands for the college of american
pathologists what they basically do is
it's an organization to help ensure that
your lab maintains the highest standards
for accurate test results and improving
patient care and safety the other reason
why it's important is because this opens
up so many doors for lots of
opportunities and partnerships with
other companies that need testing
whether it's for testing results or
researching new drugs and that's just a
surface if you want to apply for cap the
very first step is to go to the website
and apply it cap.org shocking i know and
once you do that they should send you a
welcome kit with links to resources as
well as an onboarding call with a cap
representative who will guide you
through the process just to give you a
heads up there's a deadline of around
three months to complete the application
so you want to make sure that you
actually finish it within that time
period otherwise you might have to
reapply the second step is that you will
receive a multiple customized checklist
for your lab based on the type of test
in your lab does in order to receive cap
accreditation for example if you only do
kova testing you may have to tackle like
four checklists to ensure that it meets
requirements now if you do something
like cannabis and cova testing then
you'll probably have many more
checklists and this will be really hard
to describe for you specifically and
your lab because well it's customized so
this means that you have various
departments and perform different types
of testing then you won't have the same
exact process as another lab but what we
can show you is learning what one lab
did that we know of that got cap
accreditation and this can help you
because you can have like a rough idea
of what to expect for your lab so once
you receive the customized checklist
then you will want to schedule an
inspection date which is then mailed and
or emailed to your lab the inspection
date usually takes around six months and
this is where the real grind begins
prepping for the on-site inspection the
good old fun fun times so let's get
started with one of the most important
things to check is making sure that you
have the iq oq documentation for all of
your equipment what iqoq stands for is
installation qualification and operation
qualification and what this means is
that your instruments are installed and
functioning properly the next thing you
want to have is full documentation on
your validation and what that basically
means is that your tests that you run
are reproducible and accurate for all
samples and this is really important
because you want to have a standardized
way to actually get results no matter
who is operating the equipment and
finally you need standard operating
procedures also known as sops and
documents for everything and i mean
everything
everything first thing we're going to
cover is sop separating the sops into
three categories pre-analytical
analytical and post-analytical
pre-analytical sops are anything that's
done before you start analyzing the
sample so this can include things like
how to do specimen collection
assessioning it and listing out the
specimen types and requirements so
basically what you do with your sample
before you start actually testing it
analytical sops are where you document
the actual testing process so this means
writing out exactly what you use and do
from the beginning to the end which can
include things like manipulating the
samples using any automation or
instruments or even how the sample is
being transported within the workplace
oh
i'm doing pretty good finally the last
type is post and
okay can you scroll back up
i jinxed myself finally the last type is
post analytical sops and as the name
suggests this means documentation on
anything posts analytically this
includes things with what you do at the
reporting result is out such as how to
contact your clients how to notify
providers and correcting any reports now
another component of sops you will need
to do is cover safety and safety is huge
in the lab because you know they want
you to be safe in the lab and what
basically every lab needs is a safety
binder which includes safety
instructions and an sds and sds stands
for safety data sheets and basically you
can think of it like a gt with chemicals
and properties and how to handle
something ever goes wrong buffering your
eyes and there would be instructions on
how to rinse it out immediately or
someone started drinking some chemicals
because they thought it was water and
then they found out it was actually 100
pure water meant only for testing then
it probably would have instructions to
you know send them to a hospital or
something and that's the point of the
scs then there's also a list of
requirements for the small things that
you really don't think about but if the
time actually comes you're glad it's
there like having an eye wash within a
certain amount of feet having exit signs
on the doors easily visible and so small
things were it's very important and i
bet you're going to start noticing the
exit signs in your lab now and plus this
can also include things like having a
safety shower hand washing stations
first aid kits fire extinguishers and
making sure that everything is marked
and easily reviewed and we mean that you
want everything labeled such as certain
cleaning bottles for your workstation
and equipment so it's very clear that
you're cleaning with certain chemicals
you also have to be even specific on
when those are changed out and
scheduling it whenever it's changed yes
it's even the granular things like this
where stuff
crap can you scroll back up yes it's
even the granular things like this stuff
that cap standards look out for and then
there are things like keeping a
maintenance binder making sure the lab
is clean tracking the inventory to lab
supplies tracking the temperature and
humidity tracking the cold storage
temperatures doing all the safety
courses for lab hygiene doing all the
training and competencies for every
process and that's just the main
overview i did warn you it would be a
lot of sops that's typically why cap
accreditation typically takes around two
years because you have to get all this
documented all of it and then they have
to implement it and ensure that it's
followed otherwise there isn't much
point to the documentation
we know that media lab has something
called an inspection proof where you can
upload the checklist that cap provides
which is super helpful because it helps
you keep track of the nitty-gritty stuff
plus the reason why people like having
an online system is because you can have
all the documents organized online and
stored in one place it's time to say
modern guys so instead of having those
tons of binders with papers we highly
recommend that you check out an online
system now the next thing to cover is
the documentation for training and i
think you may start to get an
understanding what cap is looking for
but you want documentation on everything
the goal is that you want to make sure
that all the lab techs and anyone in the
lab performs processes in a standardized
way and knows exactly what to do with
every scenario and how to use each lab
equipment properly this means that they
need one documented training and then
two a competent
competent
competency
con
how do you say that word competency
assessment this is especially important
if you do multiple kinds of tests for
example let's say you do kova testing
and then you also do gut testing your
lab and let's say during cover 19 that
all the lab techs are primarily doing
kova testing they have it muscle memory
on the exact routine since they've been
doing it for over a year but then
someone needs gut testing and what we
want to make sure is that they could
have potentially forgotten a step or two
during the gut testing because someone
needed it and that's the purpose of the
internal competency to make sure that
the lab tech can still perform a gut
test with the right skills and knowledge
so once you complete those internal
training documents you also need a place
to store your personal documentation for
each employee this includes at a minimum
your education degree your resume job
description and license if applicable
something to consider is also having
documentation on how to navigate your
limb system and how to use it properly a
limb system is a laboratory information
management system which basically helps
you to effectively manage samples and
associate the data in an organized way
basically you can easily track the
progress of your samples it can also
include things like tracking reagents
tracking your inventory management
tracking your sample management the
process of the samples and even
reporting your results out and finally
you want to enroll in a proficiency
testing program i know cap has a program
but there's also other programs like the
american proficiency institute or they
send samples with a known result and you
just want to make sure that you can get
the same results as them to verify that
your testing is accurate because if it's
not then well
it's going to be a huge red flag that
some parts of your testing may not be
right and once you finish all of that
then you await the on-site inspection
date they'll be using the same
customized checklist so there should be
no surprises and you will receive a copy
of their report at the end so if there
are any deficiencies or some things that
you may have missed then you have 30
days to respond to any deficiencies they
will then review your application
hopefully you will receive your cap
accreditation certificate by mail to the
lab director and you're basically at the
finish line the last thing you want to
do is you want to maintain this cap
accreditation after all the hard work
you did and you just want to perform
self-inspection and just make sure that
you maintain compliance so that you
don't lose it so that's the overview
creating documentation for every single
thing in your lab and following it if
you like this video be sure to like and
subscribe this channel peace out
[Music]
dang it
oh man